This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6MtEnglish
From BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello and welcome to 6 Minute English I'm Sophie
And I'm Neil. Here's a coffee Sophie
Neil, remember that staff meeting we had yesterday?
Why did you agree to having Deak have coffee in the kitchen
when I know you don't like it and neither do I?
I know. It's just that the boss said that Deak
caffeinated coffee, that's coffee with the caffeine removed.
It was a good idea, healthier you know.
And then everyone else agreed and I, I don't know,
I just felt uncomfortable disagreeing with everyone.
Well it's interesting you should say that Neil.
Group Think is the subject of today's show.
Group Think refers to the type of bad decisions we make
when we are in a group. Decisions that are contrary to
or against what we really think.
A psychology experiment conducted in the 1950s
showed that a lot of people do exactly that.
They submit to the will of the group.
But before we hear more about this,
now would be a good time for today's quiz question
and I get to ask you Sophie.
Okay, what is it?
In which story by Hans Christian Andersen does a young boy
dare to tell the truth when everyone else goes along with an obvious lie?
Is it A, the red shoes?
B, the snow queen or C, the emperor's new clothes?
Okay, I think it's C, the emperor's new clothes.
Well, we'll find out later on in the show if that's right or not.
Now, the psychologist Solomon Ash is well known for his conformity experiments
from the 1950s. Can you tell us what conformity means please Sophie?
Conformity means behavior that is the same as the way most other people behave.
Ash's main finding was that group pressure
can change a person's opinion of even obvious facts.
And what did this ash test involve?
123 male participants were shown a card with a line on it,
followed by another card with three lines on it.
The participants were then asked to say which line
matched the line on the first card in length.
The right answer was plain to see,
but the participants felt pressurised into saying the wrong answer.
Why would they do that?
Because the majority of people taking part in the experiment
have been told to give the wrong answer.
Let's hear Professor Nick Chaiter's explanation.
He works at the Warwick Business School here in the UK.
By the time it comes to you, a whole list of people have said something plainly wrong.
And you are either going to have to fold and say, well, I just agree with them,
or you're going to rather uncomfortably say, well, I think it's one actually.
And most people most of the time tend to fold.
Professor Nick Chaiter uses the word fold, which means you give up.
But Sophie, if people are uncomfortable about supporting the wrong answer
or something they don't believe in, why do they do it?
Because even though we might feel uncomfortable going along with
or agreeing with something we don't believe, we're even more uncomfortable
about disagreeing with the group.
Well, I didn't realise that people were such sheep.
I have a will of steel, Sophie.
Haha, that's right.
So your will of steel or strong determination somehow melted away in the staff meeting,
yes, did I suppose?
Ah, well, of course, yes, please.
Let's move on and consider briefly how social media encourages group things.
Yes, there's a real danger with something like, for example, the Twitter,
the social networking service, because when an opinion on Twitter starts to trend,
it can take on a momentum of its own and people adopt it simply because it's popular,
not because they really believe it.
And momentum means a force that keeps something going once it has started.
Let's hear from journalist and author John Ronson.
He has an interesting opinion about this.
One of the ironies here is that on social media, we all like to see ourselves as non-conformists,
but when we all get together in a group, what we're doing is using our individual non-conformity
to create a more conformist world.
So if somebody steps out of line, all us non-conformists in this frightened conformist way
tear them apart, it's like we're defining the boundaries of normality by tearing apart the people
on the outside.
John Ronson, are you a non-conformist then Neil?
Someone who thinks and behaves differently from other people?
I'm not the type that John Ronson's describing.
One who joins up with other so-called non-conformists to bully people with different views.
Now, remember I asked you earlier, in which story by Hans Christian Anderson
does a young boy dare to tell the truth when everyone else goes along with an obvious lie?
Is it A, the red shoes, B, the snow queen, or C, the emperor's new clothes?
I guess C, the emperor's new clothes.
And you were?
Right, so you think?
Yay!
The emperor's new clothes is a story by Hans Christian Anderson about two weavers who promise
an emperor a new suit of clothes that is invisible to those who are stupid or incompetent.
No one dares to say that he doesn't see any suit of clothes and sort of child cries out,
but he isn't wearing anything at all.
It's a great story and a lesson to us all.
Now, can we hear the words we learnt today please?
They are decaffeinated, group think, contrary to conformity,
fold, going along with, will of steel, momentum, non-conformist.
Well, that's the end of today's six-minute English.
Don't forget to join us again soon.
Bye-bye!